[Music]
on this saturday night murder in mexico
canadians killed near a well-known
tourist town
the search for a suspect and how canada
is responding
treacherous conditions an arctic blast
plunges the eastern u.s into a dangerous
deep freeze
investigating the tonga eruption what
scientists are learning about the
volcanic powerhouse in the south pacific
have you seen the girl
and leaving her stamp on music history
at 102 years old
one doesn't expect to even be remembered
honoring canada's first lady of jazz
[Music]
global national reporting tonight
sophie louis
evening and thanks for joining us we are
learning more tonight about a deadly
shooting in mexico involving canadians
three people were shot at a popular
resort it happened yesterday at hotel
ishkaret just south of playa del carmen
a tourist area along mexico's caribbean
coast mexican authorities say two men
were killed and a woman is recovering in
hospital they also allege that the
gunman in the brazen attack is a
canadian he remains at large michaela
couture has more on the deadly shooting
and a warning this story may be
disturbing to some viewers
webcam images capture what was nearly a
picture perfect day at the mexican
resort
[Applause]
five bangs believed to be gunshots ring
out this video appears to show the scene
afterwards with three bodies laying on
the floor in an eating area definitely a
shock that it happened in a resort
canadian travel advisor lori gold lives
10 minutes from the resort and while she
was surprised she doesn't feel less safe
you know people have to realize that
life is still light even in paradise but
typically it does not affect tourists at
all it is not anywhere near tourism it
is really super targeted local police
claim the shooting was linked to
organized crime reports say two men are
dead while one woman is in hospital all
three are believed to be canadian the
gunman seen in this photo released by
the local secretary of public security
is still on the loose global affairs
canada won't confirm the identities of
the three canadians but did say consular
officials are working with local
authorities and are providing consular
assistance
while locals seem to feel safe there has
been a spate of shootings in recent
months that are getting a lot of
attention because they were in tourist
areas or involved tourists in october an
american and german were killed after
getting caught in the apparent crossfire
of rival drug dealers a month later at
least 10 gunmen stormed the beach of a
luxury hotel near cancun in the past you
have
four five major criminal organizations
now
because of
different factors you have
45-50 different
criminal groups fighting for the
territory the mexican government is
trying to address the crimes while
protecting the lucrative tourist
industry according to walter mckay an
expert in policing and security in
mexico the
tourist police they call them who are
trained in english and other popular
language such as german so they can deal
with tourists who need assistance
because they have a vested interest to
protect this billion dollar plus economy
an economy that could take a hit after
an apparent organized crime hit at a
resort
mike lacouter global news ottawa
to the situation in ukraine the u.s
embassy in kiev has reportedly requested
the evacuation of all non-essential
staff as fierce mount of an imminent
russian invasion the first shipment of a
200 million dollar arms delivery
promised by president joe biden arrived
in kiev overnight the u.s embassy says
the shipment demonstrates its firm
commitment to ukraine's sovereign right
to self-defense russia has amassed tens
of thousands of troops along its borders
with ukraine even as moscow denies it
has any plans to invade
and russia continues to flex its
military muscles stepping up drills in
belarus moscow says fighter jets have
begun relocating for military exercises
to be held near its border with nato
members poland and lithuania and close
to ukraine russia's defense ministry
says two battalions carrying
anti-aircraft missile systems are also
moving to western belarus
now to the pandemic and there are early
indications the omicron wave may have
reached its peak nationally over the
last week confirmed case rates have
dropped and sewage surveillance is also
showing positive signs
wastewater testing is an alternate
method for tracking covet 19. it's being
championed for providing important
information on outbreaks but as ross
lord explains not all public health
authorities are sold on its merits
researchers are not surprised waste
water testing is emerging as a go-to
method for finding covert 19. developers
of alberta systems say it detects covert
19 up to a week before positive cases
are confirmed clinically making it a
valuable tool in pandemic response for
example the
reinstatement of masking in calgary that
decision was informed in part by
wastewater testing and that really shows
that wastewater testing can be part of
the evidence base that policymakers use
to make these critical decisions in how
we navigate the pandemic not surprising
when you consider the virus survives a
long time in the gastrointestinal tract
and samples are contributed unknowingly
by everyone when they go to the bathroom
i think what we've seen in alberta is
that this technology really works
we had to iron out some kinks like other
teams across canada and around the world
it seems smoothing out some kinks is
ongoing a team that developed a
wastewater testing system at dalhousie
university raised eyebrows by claiming
it found the omicron variant in halifax
in mid-november weeks before it was
publicly reported in nova scotia even
before it was reported by south africa
but nova scotia's top doctor was not
convinced we've actually had
conversations with the the researchers
and what it turned out they were
detecting the alpha variant they
actually weren't detecting omicron so
it's still a research tool that has yet
to be validated in many ways dalhousie
university says the school stands by
their team's finding a statement from
the nova scotia government says a
different sample suggests the presence
of omicron but the finding has not been
confirmed as those test results are
tested
calgary researchers are flushed with
success
their findings are posted online as
real-time data showing concentrations of
covet in various parts of the city with
wastewater testing methods evolving
researchers hope it helps canada detect
more threats to public health in the
future covert 19 or others
ross lord global news halifax
if you are planning to head to the u.s
remember there are new rules in effect
as of today all foreign travelers
including canadians who are entering the
u.s at land borders ferry terminals or
airports must show proof they are fully
vaccinated non-u.s citizens must also
declare whether their trip is for
essential or non-essential reasons while
the eastern u.s is being slammed by
winter storms frigid temperatures snow
and ice hitting the region from north to
south freezing power lines roads and
runways and prompting warnings to
drivers as far south as texas and
louisiana to stay off the roads jennifer
johnson reports
snow and ice and a delta airlines plane
skidding off the runway at
raleigh-durham international airport
friday night as severe winter weather
hit the carolinas and a section of the
eastern u.s
no one was hurt in that incident but two
medics were injured after icy roads sent
this ambulance careening off a north
carolina highway
south of the outer banks thousands have
been left without power the national
weather service issued an ice storm
warning for the morehead north carolina
region for the first time in history we
are concerned about maybe some families
who can't stay warm
and we need people to check on
their friends and neighbors
half the country has been hit by this
january arctic blast temperatures 20
degrees below normal on average i got my
boots i got my clothes my hats golf
everything wind chills hit minus 31
degrees in minneapolis brownsville texas
recorded its fifth winter storm warning
ever
warming stations were set up for people
in san antonio state officials
throughout the south have been begging
motorists to stay off the roads as they
work to keep them treated with salt
we're going to try to find any ice and
and take care of it we're going to
market as soon as we can
but
you might be the motorist who discovers
it first the big freeze seemed to freeze
over ponds and lakes but firefighters
warned that can be deceiving in new york
three children had to be rescued after
going through the ice on a pond
[Music]
and in new jersey a policeman's body
camera was rolling as a skater went
through the ice
firefighters say when it's this cold
it's hard to imagine the ice isn't
frozen solid you don't know the
thickness of the ice do not go on the
ice
the bone chilling temperatures have
millions of americans bundled up
slipping and sliding and forecasters
warn the deep freeze will stick around
through the end of the month
jennifer johnson global news washington
on the west coast winds whiffing more
than 100 kilometers an hour are fueling
a wildfire in northern california
forcing evacuations near big sur the
colorado canyon fire has grown to more
than 600 hectares and is only 5 percent
contained flames spread quickly last
night after months of drought conditions
and residents were told to pack up and
leave by 11 pm
no injuries have been reported the cause
of that fire is under investigation
coming up havana syndrome how the cia
search for answers has only deepened the
mystery
new details tonight about the mysterious
illness that's plagued hundreds of u.s
and canadian diplomats havana syndrome
first emerged in cuba in 2016. it was
initially feared a foreign power may
have been launching sonic attacks
against embassy staff using high
frequency acoustic waves but as reggie
shaquini explains a new cia report
suggests otherwise
it's a health crisis that's vexed
officials for more than five years the
so-called havana syndrome that's beset
hundreds of diplomats with cognitive and
balance issues it had been assumed it
was an act of aggression perhaps a
weapon used by a foreign nation but on
wednesday the cia rattled nerves by
ruling out hostile acts unless we see
their data as to how they came to their
analysis just making this broad blanket
statement is is worthless
the interim findings lay blame on
environmental factors or pre-existing
conditions in many cases that occurred
outside of cuba something happened to
those people in havana dr james jordano
has consulted with the state department
in its investigation and says while the
vast majority of cases are
circumstantial those initial cases in
cuba are worrisome these individuals
presented not only with subjective
symptoms
but with objective clinical signs
that are both qualitative and
quantitative
that support that something physical
happened to those individuals mark
polymeropolis came down with the
symptoms while serving in moscow this
was the most terrifying experience of my
life he's concerned the cia hasn't
investigated enough reports while
lawyers argue it's all about saving face
our view is that this is a public
relations
response because many of their people
have been
declining to go overseas to serve in
different capacities
it's not just american diplomats
searching for answers more than two
dozen canadians are suing ottawa
accusing the government of mishandling
their concerns the canadian government i
believe has not been transparent on this
the case argues ottawa hasn't done
enough to protect its staff the
diplomats in our view
have been forgotten
and essentially thrown under the bus
amid the search for answers new cases
have been reported including an incident
in vietnam ahead of a visit by the vice
president last august the u.s now
investigates these as anomalous health
incidents although jordano believes a
directed energy weapon can't be ruled
out the availability viability and
therefore validity
of these types of devices is apparent
and has been recognized
for a long time
with no definitive explanation for
dozens of cases the investigations do
continue only without accusations that
could lead to increased political
tensions
regi chikini global news washington
next the push to understand the massive
volcanic eruption that left parts of
tonga in ruins
heavy rains have caused widespread
damage in the peruvian town of machu
picchu cutting off access to the world
famous ruins officials say floods and
landslides have washed away railroads
and bridges forcing the closure of
peru's most popular tourist attraction
at least one person has been reported
missing
more international aid arrived in tonga
today a week after an undersea volcanic
eruption and subsequent tsunami hit the
pacific island nation a japanese plane
delivered emergency supplies including
cleaning equipment and much-needed
drinking water australia and new zealand
have also sent emergency shipments this
week while the people of tonga are now
in recovery mode trying to clean up some
of the catastrophic damage left behind
but there's also other work underway to
understand why the massive eruption
happened as mike armstrong reports
scientists had been watching this
volcano for years and some are hoping
their data will lead to answers
every aspect of this eruption will be
analyzed the explosion the ash cloud the
shock wave but one of the first things
being studied is simply the timeline the
evidence is suggesting now that the
system was priming glenn williams jones
is a volcanologist with simon fraser
university he says right now his concern
is for the people of tonga but that
there is an importance to understanding
what happened because it could happen
again
the tonga volcano has a major eruption
about every thousand years but when it
happens it doesn't just happen once
there's a very good chance that we will
have renewed eruptions maybe not of the
same size the same scale but
this could certainly go on for for quite
a few years
now figuring out the sequence of events
is going to be important starting with
when the volcano started popping out of
the water again in december of 2014 it
created an island between two islands
after several months it stabilized
enough that there were expeditions two
french explorers who were sailing past
the island on their worldwide voyage
became nasa's eyes and ears collecting
some of the very first images and
samples of the interior island now if
this volcano seems small that's because
only a fraction of it was visible it was
actually massive the part that could be
seen was just a small portion of the rim
around the crater it's it's your iceberg
you know the vast majority of this
volcano is underwater now last month the
volcano started puffing again letting
out pressure it was being watched this
satellite image was just prior to the
eruption and seems to show the middle
part of the island had slipped back
underwater this disappearance is very
interesting volcanologist john stix says
there are theories as to what happened
it could be that the recent puffing was
just pressure building and that led to
the eruption but the fact the island
disappeared may mean something else the
puffing could have been the magma
chamber letting out pressure until there
wasn't enough to hold up the roof it
could have collapsed leading to the
island slipping underwater and then the
eruption so i think time will tell if
this is the case or or not but i think
it's definitely at least a possibility
at this stage
understanding what happened will take
time satellites only tell a part of the
picture to see underwater and what's
left we'll take ships and sonar
equipment re-mapping the ocean floor
for now getting close enough to do that
is still too dangerous
mike armstrong global news
tributes are pouring in for a revered
zen buddhist monk who helped spread the
practice of mindfulness in the west
tiknot han died peacefully in vietnam at
the age of 95. he was a prominent
buddhist monk peace activist and leading
voice in the op in opposition to the
vietnam war he was exiled from vietnam
for 39 years over his mission to end the
conflict tiknathan lived much of his
adult life at a retreat he founded in
france but spent his final years in
vietnam at the monastery where he was
ordained today the dalai lama tweeted
the best way we can pay tribute to him
is to continue his work to promote peace
in the world
next how canadians are honoring the
remarkable careers of two women decades
after they first made history
[Music]
well she's known as one of the greatest
jazz singers ever to grace the stage in
canada and now eleanor collins is making
history once again the 102 year old
legend is being honored by canada post
with her very own stamp as katherine
ercart reports it's the latest
distinction in colin's decades-long
career
eleanor collins is a canadian legend
[Music]
have you seen the girl
known as the first lady of jazz
game now 102 years old she has received
another honor canada post has unveiled a
stamp featuring collins
i feel
wonderful
and honored
you know at 102 years old
one doesn't expect to even be remembered
born in alberta collins started
performing in the 1930s later starring
in the eleanor show making her the first
black woman to headline a tv show in
north america over the years she
performed with greats like dizzy
gillespie and oscar peterson more
recently
[Music]
she shared the stage with musician
marcus mosley she carries herself with
such dignity and with such grace and
when she stands on that stage and starts
to sing
something comes alive and you're just
you're enraptured
she's gifted she's talented and she
knows what she knows how to use that
those gifts that she has
collins also faced racism when she moved
to bc white neighbors once petitioned
against her black family living in the
same area in response collins
volunteered as a music teacher at her
children's school to help break down
barriers
to really have someone affirm
your work and life
on a postage stamp
[Music]
that is something the new stamp of
collins was illustrated by david
beliveau friends say it's about time she
received the honor and they're grateful
it has been released during her lifetime
i love her i love her forthrightness her
honesty her commitment to
believing in the positive she's a living
example of that philosophy i'm hungry
catherine cart global news
vancouver
that is global national for this
saturday night i'm sophie louie
tonight we leave you with a special step
back in time to celebrate canada's giant
leap forward in space history 30 years
ago today dr roberta bondar blasted off
becoming canada's first woman and the
world's first neurologist in space
the emotion of actually seeing it i'm a
scientist right we all learn that the
earth is the third rock from the sun but
seeing it in real time getting above and
seeing the edge of the planet and having
it rotate silently below the window
it was amazing to look off and see
starlight that doesn't twinkle and to
see an unfathomable black those are all
the things that i remember
bondar spent eight days on board nasa's
space shuttle discovery conducting a
groundbreaking study to this day her
work up there and at home has helped
cultivate curiosity and inspire
generations of canadians
thanks for watching and have a good
night
[Music]